- Welcome to The Tell Show.
We've got a wonderful,
hilarious guest this week.
We're really excited.
Lamorne Morris, he's
an actor and comedian.
He plays Winston Bishop on New Girl,
and he's also in Barbershop: The Next Cut,
which is out this week.
(rhythmic peaceful music)
So here on The Tell Show, Lamorne,
we always try to open up with
a game of Never Have I Ever.
- Each of us will say something
that we've never done,
and then if you have done it,
like if I'm like, "I've
never killed someone,"
and Isaac's like, "Of course I have."
- [Isaac] Whoa.
- You will ring a bell.
(dings)
And then you'll talk about it.
- I'm gonna start with never have I ever
auditioned for a television show.
(dings)
- I auditioned 15 times for New Girl.
- Wait, what?
- It was crazy.
- [Summer Anne] Wow.
- I auditioned for the
role of Coach originally,
got offered the part, couldn't do it
because the same day,
CBS offered me a role.
The New Girl, when I turned down the role,
they ended up offering it
to Damon Wayans Junior.
They weren't anticipating
that his show, Happy Endings,
was getting picked up for a second season.
- Damn.
This is like street fight stuff.
(laughs)
- Yeah, and so because he left,
that left a space open
for another character,
and so they came up with
the character, Winston,
and in doing so, they had
to audition 11 more times.
- So you auditioned a normal
amount of times the first time,
got the part.
- [Lamorne] Yes.
- And then because of all that kerfuffle,
you then had to come in, and
then that was 11 more times.
- Yes it was a nightmare
indeed, but it was fun,
'cause like, we built up
chemistry with the cast already.
It was literally a first-name
basis when you walk in.
"Lamorne, what's up?"
"Oh hey, Jake."
"Hey Zooey, what's goin' on?"
(laughs)
And I knew that they liked me
because they treated me differently.
Actor would come out the room,
and Zooey would walk by and go,
"Nah, that wasn't the guy."
(laughs)
And I would go, "Yes!"
She's directing this to me.
- What do you got Summer Anne?
- Never have I ever stood someone up.
(dings)
(disgusted groans)
- Okay here's the story.
I was living in San Francisco at the time
in a one bedroom with
like four other people,
and like pigeons in the walls,
and like mice that I'm like friends with,
and like eating cereal.
Basically I had worked my butt off
to get this job at this bar,
and at that time, an old friend
of mine from college had moved down,
and he started working at
this company called Facebook.
- Oh!
- And so my buddy, his name's Mike,
my buddy, Mike, kinda calls me up.
He's like, "Look, we're
really staffing up right now.
"We're really growing."
And I was like, "That's
like for college kids."
And my reply to Mike was, "You
know, I really worked hard
"to get this job at this bar.
"I kinda feel like (laughs)
"I kinda feel like things are starting
"to turn around for me.
"I feel like Facebook, you never know
"if that's going anywhere.
"That's for kids, that's college stuff.
"And I really appreciate the opportunity."
He's like, "Look, here's the
meeting, here's the time,
"just come."
- And you didn't go.
- [Isaac] And I didn't go.
It should note that Mike now owns a house
on top of Bernal Hill in San Francisco.
I was one of his groomsmen.
He flew me out and bought me
a $1,000 suit for his wedding.
He's looking at another house.
(disgusted groans)
- You stood up Mark Zuckerberg.
(laughing)
- Mark was waiting with a clipboard going,
"Oh, I love this guy so much.
"I just wanna, oh, check the
right boxes for this guy."
- "Yeah, I just wanna give
him like lots of options."
- "Oh, he's gonna be the one."
(laughing)
- My like good way of looking at my way
that I can still get out
of bed every morning,
knowing that I just like took that wrong
of a choice in my life,
is I was just like, with
that much money, I'd be dead.
Like there would've been a boat accident.
(laughing)
- So we continuing the game?
- Yeah, now you got your never,
something you've never done.
- Never have I ever
made out with a co-worker of mine.
- What are you implying?
- I'm implying I feel like if
y'all host this show together,
that at some point, some
penetration is goin' on!
(laughing)
I don't know, I don't know.
(dings)
Oh!
- Look, I have made out with a co-worker,
but not at my current job.
I worked at a bookstore
for like seven years
in my early 20s, and 20 to 27,
the only people I hooked
up with were my coworkers.
(laughing)
- Dirty.
- That's nasty.
- I mean, there was a lot of sex
that happened at the bookstore.
- Lot of sticky pages.
- That's true.
That is true, holiday parties were--
- Did you ever sleep with your boss?
- I slept with my boss, yeah.
(laughing)
- [Isaac] So casual about it.
- That's awesome.
I wanna be that boss, though, that's like,
"Yeah, I fucked all my employees."
"Where do you work, a porn shop?"
"No, a book store."
(laughing)
- Yeah, I mean there was like,
there was a web of like sexual misconduct
happening at that bookstore.
Book People, Austin, Texas.
- Wow, you just shout 'em out!
(laughing)
- Great place, I wanna be
clear, great place to buy.
- Great bookstore, great bookstore.
- Yeah, great place to buy books.
- So if I went into Book
People in Austin, Texas,
I might be standing in the wet spot.
(laughing)
That could be--
- I mean, it's been years, but you know.
- I'm gonna go in there with a black light
and see what I can find.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- [Isaac] Poor Book People. (laughing)
I think that could be
great for their business
or really bad.
- [Lamorne] I would definitely
go there. (laughing)